hi guys welcome to step number five this
is the end of this awesome series I hope
you find it also amazed now that you
finished the book I suppose that I
finished this book which is you know
Babel no more in Russian what's going to
happen is that since I marked all the
words of the border of the page all the
words that I didn't know other quarter
of the page and they put the mean of the
words I have everything here and ready
in one space and I can actually taste
the book and you know page by page I can
actually select the words that I want to
that I want to learn that are
particularly interesting that can make a
selection of the selection let me
explain to you what what I mean is that
every every time you you read a page you
will find a lot of words that you know
or you will find a certain number of
words that you turn Oh out of these
words you will mark some words two or
three or four whatever and out of these
words so if you calculate that this book
has 400 pages if you mark two words per
page the two words that either notebook
page well if you do the math it will
have 800 words but you don't need no
what do you have to do now is that not
all these words are going to be useful
for you so what I normally do is at the
end of the book I transfer this is the
passage from here to here I make a
selection of the words that I have
previously selected so for example every
20 pages I choose one or three words
that I particularly write like and I jot
them down here so I give a title a date
whatever the date and the title of the
book and I write all the content and I
can do it for maybe three or four
different days so that I'm going to
maybe jot down on this notebook maybe 50
or 100 out of the 800 words that high of
mark just to give an example normally
1/5
I just jot down and pour the content of
one fifth of the content that I have
marked here this is really important
because one
have this you can actually do a bunch of
things of creative things to actually
use the vocabulary that you learn
because much of the recovery that you
learn in books will be passive but you
can find creative ways to use these
words and I have a new website which is
called WWE lingo core comm we are
putting together a bunch of very
interesting courses where innovative and
new and you've never seen anything like
that before where you can actually apply
all these techniques and speak any
language well so I truly wish you
enjoyed the series and I'm going to talk
to you very very soon in another video
or series of videos that I'm going to
together test for you every day